fight
[Music]
I'mma tell you that you're not my
competition I'm always win throw me in
and I'm going in I ain't running I'm com
you get talk about it CU I really live
it night on the mission no fear no hope
in my vision don't no intervention you
ride even to come out point out and be
missing
here if you met me you try to be brave
and step up with your is too scary plusz
I'm too legendary it's what we go hard
for I'm rocking your block you once you
get knocked off I'm taking your place
I'm making my property maybe a game you
probably me
only
weak anytime I get into it I be looking
at I'm looking in the condition be
critical nothing less than original the
end who's
next finish
[Applause]
him
[Music]
get over
here